eq olivier delorme spécialiste de la
grèce et auteur de l ouvrage la grèce et
les balcons aux éditions gallimard
bonjour olivier delorme merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
ce matin plusieurs 12 jours
avec plaisir plusieurs dossiers donc sur
la table pour ce sommet on l'a entendu
emmanuel macron appel à plusieurs
souveraineté européenne mais aussi des
enjeux migratoires et la situation en
afghanistan après la prise le kaboul par
les talibans les afghans représentent 45
% des arrivées de migrants sur le sol
grec depuis janvier à quoi s'attendre
sur ce sujet
écoutez on peut s'attendre au pire avec
monsieur erdogan puisque depuis
maintenant plus de plus de 5 ans il joue
de larmes migratoires
qui lorgne dont ils organisent
venue de flot de migrants dans son pays
et qu'il s'en sert ensuite pour faire
chanter l'europe l'union européenne et
lui lui tirer ce qui marche d'ailleurs
des crédits à chaque vague migratoire
qu'il déclenche donc on peut
effectivement espérer et craindre le
pire et la grèce craint pire c'est à
dire que
le premier ministre grec l'a dit hier
soir nous ne permettrons pas le retour
de flux migratoires à contrôler que nous
avons connue en 2015 donc si vous voulez
c'est un avertissement à
ar dogan qu'il ne peut pas qu'il ne vous
qui qu'on ne le laissera pas en grèce en
tout cas
utiliser larmes des migrants une fois de
plus il est à noter
la grèce qui inaugure un aujourd'hui
ah çà mau son premier camp pour
demandeurs d'asile fermé et à accès
contrôlé une expression qui inquiète
tant les défenseurs des droits humains
l'an passé vous le disiez il y avait des
tensions entre la grèce et la turquie de
résultat hyper douanes le président turc
ankara qui agite vous l'avez dit le le
flux migratoires le spectre du flux
migratoire souvent tandis qu'athènes se
sent abandonné par bruxelles mais
concrètement quelles pistes seront
évoquées ce week end
écoutez vous c'est ce ce sommet comme
comme tous les sommets de ce genre sont
des sommets déclaratoire c'est à dire
que rien rien de rien de pratique ne
sortira de cette réunion on l'a vu déjà
hier avec les uns avec les déclarations
des différents chefs d'état et de
gouvernement et on a bien vu que si la
grèce ou l'italie qui sont au premier
rang de 7 2 2 au premier rang premiers
rangs pour accueillir cette vague
migratoire qui s'annonce les autres
commencent à détourner la tête et est de
toute façon les règles de schengen revue
mais revu à minima font que de toute
façon ce sont les pays d'accueil qui
doivent gérer ces flux alors bien sûr
les défenseurs des droits de l'homme
s'inquiètent de la position de la grèce
qui est de ne plus accepter sur son sol
de nouvelle vague de migrants merveille
six volets il faut comprendre que la
grèce vit depuis 10 ans sous un régime
d'exception économiques imposées par
l'union européenne qu'il a saigné à
blanc que cette que cette se saigne à
cette politique a contraint au départ
cinq cent mille jeunes grecs pour qu'ils
sont allés chercher du travail ailleurs
et que d'autres d'autre part dans ce
pays de 11 millions d'habitants qui a 20
% de chômeurs on demande à la grèce
d'assumer seul avec une une
avec une solidarité qui est purement
verbale le nouveau choc migratoires
c'est absolument inconcevable
athènes a acheté début septembre six
nouveaux rafale
à la france des avions de chasse la
grèce en a déjà commandé dix huit
récemment quels sont les enjeux
diplomatiques de l'union européenne en
méditerranée les hydrocarbures avec la
lutte avec
avec ankara la libye vous avez un énorme
gisement gazier qui a été découvert
entre chypre et la côte siro
libano israélienne et que ce gigantesque
gisement de gaz à un moment où le prix
du gaz et de l'électricité
s'envolent ce que d'ailleurs les les les
pays membres ont demandé hier à la
commission de de se soucier de ce
problème de de l'envol des prix du gaz
et d'électricité mais on se demande bien
ce que la commission peut faire sinon là
encore parlé donc il ya un enjeu
énergétique absolument absolument
fondamental puisque là les
revendications turc mettrait en cause la
souveraineté de chypre et de la grèce
sur le tuyau qui va passer en
méditerranée orientale pour amener ce
gaz en italie et en europe occidentale
donc vous avez là vous avez là un enjeu
stratégique majeur sauf que l'union
européenne est totalement divisée sur la
question et même les neuf pays parce
qu'ils sont pas qu'il n'était pas cette
cette fois ils étaient neuf ça a été
élargie à la croatie et à la slovénie
mais les noeuds ces neuf pays ne sont
pas d'accord l'année dernière malte
malte et l'espagne et l'italie faisait
partie des pays qui ont bloqué avec
l'allemagne les sanctions contre l'acte
contre la turquie et là encore dans les
déclarations qui ont fait dire ceux qui
ont été faites hier soir on a bien vu
que le premier ministre maltais et le
premier ministre espagnol
était
avait un discours vis-à-vis de la
turquie beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins fort que la france ou la
grèce donc si vous voulez ou ou chypre
donc si vous voulez parler de
souveraineté européenne dans cette
affaire c'est une vaste c'est une vaste
rigolade en réalité les pays membres de
ce groupe comme les pays de membres de
l'union européenne ont des intérêts
divergents et ils ont des politiques
divergentes la france a appuyé la appuyé
de la grèce et chypre l'année dernière
alors que l'espagne dont les pays sont
totalement vérole dans les banques sont
totalement vérolé parce qu'elles ont
acheté un lecture que deux manières de
manière insensée elles soutiennent la
turquie et malte pour d'autres raisons
parce que malte vendée des passeports
doré ou aux mafieux turc et que c'est
une une partie de ces de ses revenus
donc si vous voulez parler de
souveraineté européenne danser dans ces
conditions là est totalement absurde il
n'y a pas et il n'y aura pas de
souveraineté européenne parce qu'il n'ya
pas de peuple européen il n'ya pas et il
y à des états qui ont des intérêts
différents on l'a vu également déclinée
aussi beaucoup de divergences justement
vous abordez les incendies c'est ma
dernière question c'est un dossier qui
va être évoquée évidemment il ya eu
beaucoup de feux en cet été dans le
bassin méditerranéen les désengagements
déposée par les états signataires de
l'accord de paris mène le monde vers un
réchauffement je cite catastrophique de
2,7 degrés très loin donc des 1,5
espérer pour limiter les retombées
destructif du réchauffement s'alarme
l'onu c'est une déclaration ce matin à
six semaines de la coop 26 quelles
solutions peuvent être trouvées lors de
ce sommet à athènes au niveau des feux
de forêt du climat
écoutez on parle de renforcement du
mécanisme européen de protection civile
alors c'est très bien si vous voulez il
ya eu il ya eu effectivement lors des
incendies en grèce l'envoi et macron là
la 1 assist et la france a envoyé quatre
unités aériennes et plus de 200 pompiers
je crois sur sur place donc tout ça on
ne peut que s'en féliciter
sauf que là encore si vous voulez parler
d'europe c'était une c'est une
rigolade madame merkel n'a pas envoyé à
envoyer immédiatement
en turquie à qui elle veut vendre des
sous-marins
des avions pour combattre les feux turc
aucun avion allemand n'est venu
combattre les feux grecs et les pompiers
allemands sont arrivés au dernier moment
et trois jours ou quatre jours avant la
fin des grands incendies en grèce donc
si vous voulez il ya eu une solidarité
franco grecque il ya eu une solidarité
de certains pays avec la grèce à l'égard
de ces incendies mais il n'y a pas eu de
solidarité européenne alors on peut
toujours parler des mécanismes de ceux
ci des agendas tu cela des discuter de
démesure qu'on va prendre etc
mais tout ça ne cache une impuissance
dans les 25 des 27 les décisions à
vingt-sept ne sont jamais qu'un plus
petit dénominateur commun et ne sont
jamais une addition de volonté elles
sont une soustraction d'objection voilà
et il faut comprendre que l'allemagne
dans cette affaire à une politique qui
est une outrageusement favorable à la
turquie et que la grèce continue à
croire dans une solidarité européenne
alors qu'il n'y a pas de solidarité
européenne merci olivier delorme d'avoir
répondu à nos questions à votre message
est est passé je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialiste de la grèce et auteur de
l'ouvragé la grèce et les balcons aux
éditions gallimard